today on the matt walsh show donald
trump is pushing back against mail-in
voting because he's concerned about
voter fraud but i think the real problem
with mail-in voting and with our
system of voting in general is different
though it is far
more politically incorrect to discuss
but we'll discuss it today
because that's what we do also five
headlines including murderers and other
dangerous criminals are now having their
cases dropped in oklahoma
after the supreme court ruled that wide
swaths of the state are indian territory
so we'll talk about that madness
and in our daily cancellation we will
discuss the pro-lifers who were arrested
in dc for having a pro-life message
writing a pro-life message in chalk on
the sidewalk
meanwhile the mayor has had her own
preferred political messages painted
in huge letters across entire city
blocks is that not viewpoint
discrimination we'll
talk about all of that on the way but
first the show today is brought to you
by
ziprecruiter you know business owners
know better than i do that
hiring is difficult um it's just very
hard to
find qualified applicants that will and
can perform
all of the relevant job duties and it's
probably never been harder than it is
right now
and that's why if you're a business
owner you have to take advantage of a
service that makes that easier for you
and that's where zip recruiter comes in
uh if you're a company
that's currently trying to to hire
you're facing new difficulties from
safely reopening your doors to finding
the right person for a specialized role
in the midst of everything that's
happening and a lot of companies can
relate that housing wire uh could relate
just one example they needed to hire an
ambitious reporter to cover news stories
on the u.s mortgage and um housing
markets so they turned to
zip recruiter to help them out and zip
recruiters
smart uh matching technology finds
people
you know with the right experience for
your job and in fact uh
this is how good they are four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day okay so 24 hours 4 out of 5
are finding someone that's how housing
wire found alexandra roja
who ended up being exactly what they
needed for the job zip recruiter
they were able to this is what they do
they matched alexandria to housing wires
reporter job
because her degree and her writing
skills were a great fit for that role
and they've done this you know millions
of times for many candidates and many
many employers housing wire received her
application um
only four hours after they posted the
job and a few weeks later
alexandra started her dream career uh
and this is a story as i said it's
played out many times so see how zip
recruiter can help you hire
try it now for free at ziprecruiter.com
walsh that's
ziprecruiter.com
walsh all right um
protests of course continued over the
weekend and i feel like i begin
every monday with that sentence protest
continued
probably isn't necessary at this point
to say it um and it probably isn't
necessary either
to do this but i will anyway here's a
very quick montage showing some of what
happened
uh in portland over the weekend watch
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if that looked like a bible they were
burning that's because it was a bible we
have now officially reached the book
burning phase of things
but i suspect that anyone who has
remained sympathetic to the protesters
through all of this
will not be disturbed by by this
development of book
burning um you know sure i'll i'll align
myself with book burners no problem
because
that always works out well historically
right now
nothing to be disturbed about here um
but the incident from this weekend that
i really want to focus on is
this little exchange down in austin
protesters were once again blocking the
roads just
sort of standing aimlessly in the street
as they do
interfering with people's lives simply
for the sake of interfering
and then a black man drove up who
apparently didn't have time
for their nonsense
i appreciate it but i gotta go to work i
gotta go to work i got bills
i got kills getting [ __ ] out of my way
i'm about to earn this
job
i gotta go
i got bills i got kids i got to go to
work he raises a good point doesn't he
and that and that point again raises a
question often posed about these
protesters which is
do these people have jobs apparently not
i mean they're out in the street every
single day for weeks on end holding
signs
it's hard to see how they can be
gainfully employed in the midst of all
of that so
we have a bunch of people who aren't
really contributing to society who
aren't productive adult members of
society
but who nonetheless expect us to listen
to their political views and take them
seriously
my question is why should we why should
we take them seriously
now granted the government has put
millions of people out of work with a
series of some of the
worst policy decisions we've seen
certainly in modern times anyway
and you could always use that as an
excuse for them
it's not their fault that they're
unemployed and you know and
they have nothing else to do and and
that's all goes back to the government
you might argue
but i don't fully buy that excuse
because for one thing if you did lose
your job because of the lockdowns
i would think you'd probably be spending
your time pursuing other job
opportunities rather than protesting
but for another more to the point
perhaps this is not a new thing the left
has a never-ending supply of people who
have nothing to do but protest
and this is something that easily
predates the pandemics you can't really
blame it on that
how quickly quickly we all forget it was
only back last fall that
environmentalist wackos
you remember this they were they were
doing the same thing all over the
country um
and in other countries too standing in
the middle of the street blocking
traffic
sometimes even blocking trains from
going by commuter trains
this went on for weeks um there was no
pandemic there was no shutdown then
and there wasn't a pandemic or a
shutdown back when we had the first
round of blm protests starting with the
uh
justified killing of the violent
criminal michael brown
so while the shutdowns are no doubt a
contributing factor the fact remains
simply that that shutdowns or no there
is a sizable portion of the american
public that apparently can afford
to spend their days doing activism
because
someone else mommy and daddy perhaps or
uncle sam maybe one of those family
members is supporting them and funding
their lifestyles
what we find in that video that i just
played and in so many other
videos like it that we've seen is the
stark divide between on the one hand
people who have nothing to offer society
who are just standing in the street
getting in everybody's way and calling
that activism
and on the other hand the people who
actually keep the country going
the people like that man in the car the
people who pay all the taxes
support families and do all of the
actual work
sustaining and maintaining maintaining a
human society
now i guess we're supposed to believe or
pretend to believe that both
groups have equally valid and important
points of view and that
both groups should be listened to and
taken seriously but i disagree
i'm not really interested in what the
latter group in fact i'm i should say
i'm only really interested in what the
latter group
the real grownups have to say
and that brings us to i think a related
issue mail-in voting
you know president trump has obviously
been on a tear recently making a fuss
about all the states that are planning
to push mail-in voting
for the election in november uh the
primary concern trump seems to have
about this
the primary concern that many on the
right have about this
is voter fraud and i understand that
concern i think that there's validity to
it
um but i also think that the right wing
obsession with voter fraud kind of
misses the point
and is in a way an easy out
a more politically correct route around
the real issue with voting and with our
democratic process
as it currently functions the real
problem with voting
and i've argued this many times and this
is by extension the problem even more so
with mail-in voting
is that there are too many people doing
it and it's too easy to do
this has already been the case with
voting in general mail-in voting will
only exacerbate
the ever-present problem if voting is
not
important enough to you if it's not
enough of a priority
to expend any real effort to do it
then you shouldn't be voting at all your
voice is not needed and would probably
do more harm than good
in the voting booth anyway and if you
are a non-contributing ignoramus
someone who has no real stake in society
and who contributes nothing of substance
to it who is not productive
and who knows nothing about our system
then
you should not be able to participate in
it at least in the capacity of a voter
you know voting ought to be a privileged
reserve for informed
grown-up contributing members of society
if you aren't paying taxes then you
shouldn't have any say in where tax
money
other people's money goes and if you are
woefully ignorant of even the most basic
facts of our system
then you shouldn't be able to by
wandering into a voting booth or worse
by by mail from your home muddy the
waters by
randomly casting a ballot ignorantly
with no idea of what you're even doing
you know we don't let people drive on
highways that way
why should we let them drive the
republic that way the consequences after
all are just as dire if not
considerably more so now
i wouldn't advocate for taking first
amendment rights away from protesters
who are ignorant non-contributing
dummies
as tempting of a thought as that might
be at times no they have the right to
speak their mind of course um but they
don't have the right to do it in the
middle of the highway
but and they don't have the right to do
it while throwing molotov cocktails
but my concern is that the attitude
we're told we're supposed to have
towards these protesters the idea that
their opinion is just as valid as
anybody
else's also makes its way into the
voting booth
um and it shouldn't you know if you're
not an informed
tax paying citizen willing to expend a
minimal effort
to you know to register your vote middle
minimal effort meaning just leaving your
home on one particular day
going to a polling place and voting then
you shouldn't be allowed to vote
ignorant non-contributing non-productive
people
can march through the city annoying
everyone as is their right
but they shouldn't have the right to to
dictate the direction of the country
via the ballot box and this is why there
should be
some very basic restrictions to
determine who can vote voting should be
reserved for people who are tax paying
adults
and adults these days probably means
more like 25 instead of 18
with extended adolescence being a real
issue as well so
tax paying adults who can pass a basic
sixth grade civics exam that's my that's
my proposal these restrictions would not
exclude anyone based on basic facts
about their biolog
biological identity which they can't
control or change
obviously excluding people from voting
based on sex race ethnicity is wrong and
illegal and should
be but excluding people based on
behavior and choices
is another thing altogether voting
is not a god-given right endowed by the
creator and meant to be shared by all
people
no matter what we already restrict
voting based on several factors
and not all factors that actually a
person can change
as it stands right now if you're seven
years old
you can't vote uh if you're a convicted
serial killer
you can't vote most peop now the left is
trying to change
both both of those okay they're going
way in the other direction
and as always the left has no problem
advocating for things that seem radical
and in fact are radical
until they don't seem radical anymore
because they get their way so they're
they're they're just gonna they're gonna
go
you know they're gonna shoot for the
mountaintops all the time and so now
there are leftists who would say yeah oh
yeah
convicted serial killer should vote from
prison um if they're even imprisoned
if we even keep them in prison at all uh
children should vote
maybe eventually the right will learn to
to do the same thing rather than
constantly
you know move as as the left moves the
culture
moves the you know as they're as they
are advocating for the most extreme
leftist position
they move the mainstream position left
with them
and what the right always does is they
move along with the mainstream position
they always want to stay there in the
mainstream because they say well if
we're too radical no one's going to
listen
but the right should be responding with
the opposite say no
no no no this is this is not this is not
how we
how how you run a functioning society
by trying to involve literally everyone
in the voting process even to the point
where eventually yes they're going to
have 12 year olds out there voting
as it stands right now though
most people who are not radical leftists
would say now probably if i were to make
a guess about what most people in the
mainstream would think
everything i've said so far many people
the mainstream would think that's too
extreme that's
even horrific and horrible how dare you
voting is a sacred
right and how dare you say these things
uh yet
i would also guess most of those people
would say that well sure we're not going
to have 12 year olds vote
why not though why don't we have 12 year
olds vote
if you're not in favor of 12 year olds
voting why
it's and don't it's not enough to say oh
they're minors what does it have to do
with anything who cares if they're
minors
we call them miners fine but what is it
about them
that should exclude them from voting
could i suggest what it might be
i think it's that they're not productive
contributing members
tax-paying members of society and they
don't know a damn thing about the system
they are ignorant and non-productive now
when they're 12 that's not their fault
all 12-year-olds are that way 12 years
are supposed to be that way
um but so
if if we exclude 12 year olds on that
basis
why shouldn't we exclude 32 year olds on
that basis
so if the 12 year old we say the 12 year
old you can't vote because you're
ignorant and non-contributing
and then when they turn 18 even if
they're still ignorant and
non-contributing we say okay you can
vote now
why why don't we just let them vote when
they were 12 in that case what's the
difference
so i do think this is a discussion we
should be having more often uh in
in if we're going to be talking about uh
you know problems with our voting system
rather than focusing all the time on
voter fraud voter fraud voter fraud
i think this is the real sort of fraud
that's being perpetuated on our system
and we should be talking about it all
right let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
historic moment this weekend the spacex
dragon capsule made a water landing as
the two astronauts
uh returned from the international space
station after two months orbiting the
earth
this was probably this was this was not
probably this was the first splashdown
by
american astronauts in 45 years i
believe so you can check it out here you
see the footage um
that's got to be disconcerting i mean
you know among other things i just i i
cause i think i get freaked out by
landings just on a you know
a delta flight from chicago to baltimore
uh that
that whole experience freaks me out
being on a plane i i'm high anxiety on
planes
and everywhere else in life to be honest
but especially landing
um so just imagine descending 250 miles
from orbit
and landing in the ocean with in a big
capsule with parachutes attached
here's um astronaut doug hurley
expressing his thanks to the team
um and getting understandably emotional
after after landing safely safely listen
to this
go for spacex here we have our first
view
of i just would like to sort of
reiterate what bob said
and add my thanks to uh
everybody over the last several years
that's either worked in hawthorne
mcgregor or down at the kennedy space
center
anybody who's touched endeavor you
should
take a moment to just cherish this day
especially given all the things that
have happened this year
we certainly can't thank you enough our
families can't thank you enough
[Music]
just proud to be a small part of this
whole effort
to get the accompany
people to and from the space station
they can celebrate with each other cease
and desist
thanks so much doug and you're welcome
and and thank you so much for those kind
words
and we all wish you a safe journey home
and a happy reunion with your family
soon and we look forward to seeing you
in person as well
got to think about the relief he must
feel in getting out into the open air
again
he was cooped up with other astronauts
for two months now granted the iss is
pretty big it's like
equivalent to a five or six bedroom
house but even so
two months unable to leave unable unable
to go for a walk even
except a spacewalk has to be uh
a challenge another interesting fact
about the iss that i just learned and
i'll mention it because i looked it up
on google so i was curious
um i knew it traveled fast around the
earth i didn't realize that it goes 17
000 miles an hour orbiting the earth
orbiting the entire earth every 90
minutes
so i'm guessing that's something you
probably try not to think about when
you're
strapped up to a tether and walking
around the outside of that thing
but i don't know great story there
number two not so great story the boston
marathon bomber
dzhokhar tsarnaev who murdered three
people and wounded hundreds of others
just had his death sentence thrown out
by a federal appeals court
now to go back to the lower courts and
this thing will drag on even longer
the reason for throwing it out as
reported by the ap is that supposedly
quote the judge oversaw the case did not
adequately screen
jurors for potential biases
and you know
this is why so this guy's been he
committed his crime seven years ago
just throughout the death penalty
sentence this is why the way we handle
the death penalty in modern america is
absurd
you know this guy there's no question
that he's guilty he's confessed to it
there's no doubt about the guilt in a
case like that
mass killer high profile
act of terrorism no question about guilt
been convicted
um he should be taken out back and
dispatched 30 minutes
after the trial concludes
what do we need all the appeals for
do not pass go do not collect 200 do not
sit idly in a jail cell for seven years
or 27 years
just take them right to the gallows take
care of it with a rope or a firing squad
cheap easy done and that's justice
and it would also be a good thing for
any potential future murdering scumbags
to know
that the moment they're convicted
they're dead
this isn't going to be 20 years of
appeals the moment you hear that
we find the defendant guilty and then
the sentencing happens
you're done for it um kiss your mama
goodbye because
that's it maybe they say that one of the
people who oppose the death penalty will
often
argue that there's no deterrent factor
with the death penalty
i don't know if that's true or not i'm
not sure how you could even
say one way or another because it
requires you to
look into the minds of of killers and
and
determine whether they were deterred or
not i i don't know if you can
really determine that but if there
is little deterring effect to the death
penalty now
maybe there'd be a lot more of a
deterring effect if it happened
immediately after sentencing
and that way it becomes more real to
the potential murdering scumbag just a
thought
three speaking of federal courts making
terrible decisions you may recall the
supreme court last month announcing that
a huge swath
of oklahoma is actually somehow an
indian reservation
what that means is that the state of
oklahoma can no longer prosecute
crimes committed on this quote-unquote
reservation
all of that now goes to the feds which
means that a whole slew of violent
criminals
will now get to walk free as the feds
sort through the mounds of paperwork and
figure out what to do with all these new
cases
the new york times reports uh one
example of this one of many
a woman named kelsey lip was sitting in
jail charged with robbing and
killing a man in fact here's what she
did she allegedly did
she lured a 25 year old man named dustin
barham
into her apartment allegedly at which
point
he was robbed shot and and then bled to
death
now she gets to go free for the time
being
because her public defender uh was able
to
to produce her tribal identification
card
so because her distant ancestors
lived in an indian tribe that means that
she gets to
for now get away with allegedly robbing
and shooting and killing a man
um and this isn't this is not an
isolated case many violent criminals who
are awaiting trial or
or who have already been convicted now
stand to be released while the feds
figure out how to handle this delusion
of new cases but but this also can
happen
um not just if the suspected criminal
was a tribal member but even if the
victim was a travel mentor
here's a another case from the article
it says dustin dennis who prosecutors
said was not a tribal member
was charged with second-degree murder in
july after his young son and daughter
tegan age 4 and ryan 3
were found dead in his sweltering pickup
the children climbed into the car were
apparently overcome by the heat
while mr dennis slept according to
prosecutors
tulsa county prosecutors had to drop the
case when it turned out that the
children were cherokee on their mother's
side
mr dennis was charged federally with
child neglect but
the tulsa district attorney said it had
been devastating to tell the children's
mother he was dropping the case
so um that might be a surprising aspect
of this for people
was for me as well that it's not just if
the criminal but even if if
a if a victim a child
is a tribal member then that means that
their killer gets to
at least for the time being walk free
number four lena dunham um my my
personal favorite actress
posted on instagram revealing that uh
she had coveted a few months ago
and she wanted to tell her story and the
reason to tell her story was to slap
some sense into the quote careless
people
who do reckless and dangerous things
like jog without face masks
that's what she's worried about because
yeah imagine that very reckless
you got to make sure you wear that face
mask while you jog because uh
you know you wouldn't want to contract
covet 19 while you're running down the
street
i mean there hasn't been any confirmed
cases of that at all
happening but still it could happen so
make sure you wear that face mask don't
be reckless
but then lena starts dramatically um
recounting
her tale of sickness and this is this is
what she says let me pull it up
i got sick with covet 19 in mid-march it
started with achy joints which i was
unable to distinguish from my usual
diagnosis so i didn't freak out but the
pain was soon joined by an impossible
crushing fatigue
then a fever of 102 suddenly my body
simply revolted
the nerves in my feet burned and muscles
wouldn't seem to do their job
my hands were numb i couldn't tolerate
loud noises i couldn't sleep but i
couldn't wake up i lost my sense of
taste and smell
a hacking cough like a metronome kept
timing kept
keeping time inability to breathe after
simple tasks like getting a glass of
water
random red rashes a pounding headache
right between my eyes
it felt like i was a complex machine
that had been unplugged and then had my
wires rerouted into the wrong inputs
this was on for this went on for 21 days
days that blended into each other like a
rave gone wrong
i was lucky enough to have a doctor who
could offer me regular guidance on how
to care for myself
and i never had to be hospitalized this
kind of hands-on attention is a
privilege that is far too unusual in our
broken healthcare system
i self-isolated with my pulse oximeter
uh
monitoring my levels after a month i
tested negative for covenanting
was able to spend time around my
isolation pot again
i couldn't believe how intense the
loneliness had been in addition to the
illness
okay and she goes on from there
describing it but
i have to say yeah it sounds like she
was she was sick
uh very sick and i'm glad she recovered
but
most of what she recounted there in in
dramatic terms
with creative analogies and metaphors
and all of that
also describes my experience with the
flu which i had back in february
um i was very sick for several days had
a fever
considerably higher than 102 actually
and um
and and i did have to go i was in
hospital i wasn't admitted but i did
have to go to the hospital for
and then i had symptoms that wiped me
out
i was exhausted for like a month after
that
um even after the fever went away i it
dragged on for weeks after that i felt i
just felt kind of wiped out
and not myself my point is not that
kovit is the flu my point is that
with kovid people especially famous
people celebrities
will tend to recount their experience
with covet in this over the top dramatic
way
expressly to scare you i mean she admits
that that's what she's trying to do
she wants to scare you into wearing a
mask while you jog so there's an agenda
behind this
um and it's it's it's just it's
dishonest
i'm not it's not this i'm not saying
that she doesn't she didn't have covet i
believe she had covet
i don't think she's lying about that but
the story she's really telling here
is a story of being pretty sick not
deathly sick
but pretty sick 102 okay for a little
while
and then getting better okay that's what
actually happened
when you boil this down to the basics it
didn't hap doesn't happen that away for
everybody there are people who i there
are many people who have died from it
there are people who get a lot more sick
than that there are people that get
hospitalized
but the story she's telling she was she
was pretty darn sick
for a little while then she got better
so why not say that
why the effort to turn this into a
cinematic fight for your life
well again we know why she's clear about
why there's an agenda behind it she
and she wants to scare you into behaving
the way that she thinks you should
behave
so we should just keep that in mind when
we read these sorts of things finally i
want to show you this
this was posted by speaking of dramatic
um the sun a uk newspaper
posts some truly shocking footage i mean
this is mind-bending
mind-blowing mind-boggling okay
all of that you're not going to believe
this
this again was posted by a news outlet
just to be clear
and they wanted to demonstrate how hot
it's been in the uk apparently they're
in the middle of a little
heat wave and so they wanted to show how
hot it's been
and this is the video that this news
outlet posted watch
[Music]
[Applause]
wow amazing
it it's it's so hot
that it melts ice cream if you keep the
ice cream in the sun
for 20 minutes my god
i have never seen anything like that
before i
have you ever seen that i have never
seen ice cream i've never heard of that
i've never heard of that happening i
didn't know that
you're telling me that if you bring an
ice cream cone out into the
heat in the summer in july
august now you're telling me it will
melt
melt really uh
just absolutely
amazing truly global warming is going to
kill us all
and our ice cream even worse so that's
um that's pretty big news just wanted to
share that with you
we're gonna go to our daily cancellation
before we do if you're not a daily wire
all-access member you know you're really
missing out all access is our most
exclusive membership tier featuring
behind the scenes access to
us your podcast hosts as well as writers
and special guests all access members
are also given
early access to new daily wired products
and as part of that i'm excited to
announce our brand new
limited count collectors edition
baseball bat in collaboration with
pillbox bat company um
to be honest with you they want me to
talk here about why baseball is the
greatest sport i just i feel
i football's the greatest sport just to
be clear in my opinion i can't
i cannot defy um what i know to be true
but baseball's also uh the great
american pastime there's no denying that
and this uh this this collector's
edition um
uh baseball bat is something you really
need it's handcrafted here in the u.s
and emblazoned with the daily wire logo
and this
uh run of bats will each be engraved
with the individual number in the order
they were
they were produced from one to one
hundred these bats are currently only
being offered to our all access
membership tier
so join our upgrade now before they're
all gone all access members also get to
participate in all access live
where one of our daily wire hosts hangs
out with you for a live discussion
yesterday was a very special live stream
we just talked about the spacex
landing daily wire's own jeremy boring
watch the return of the spacex dragon
capsule and crew with all access members
hosted a discussion with them afterwards
that was very interesting
so you get a lot of really just special
content like that too so if you're not
an all-access member head over to
dailywire.com
walsh to get your two yes two leftist
tears tumblers and 20
off with coupon code access right now
that's dailywire.com
walsh okay um today for our daily
cancellation we're gonna be canceling
i'm not sure who gets it here exactly
it's uh the mayor of dc maybe the
the city of dc dc cops
i guess everyone will just cancel
everyone uh because of this watch
this is our constitutional right
we do this every saturday so
we can tell you now that if you continue
copying
okay
you know they do this every saturday
right okay saturday
this is completely public in political
science
this is public property every saturday
people are here talking and you're
taking somebody young people and
arresting them because they are
simply putting these black freeborn
lives
matter you gotta be joking
you gotta be absolutely joking that you
would take
young people that are simply putting on
a sidewalk
talk that they are standing for pre-born
black lives
you absolutely have to be joking we're
standing
in front of an abortuary where they kill
children every day and you're taking
young people away to the police
department because they're simply
putting chalk
on a sidewalk what you watched there was
uh there was a students first
for um students for life in dc
they were attempting to write black
pre-born lives matter in chalk
on the sidewalk in front of a planned
parenthood butcher shop
they were arrested for it now as was
pointed out by the pro-lifers on the
scene
this is especially egregious given the
fact that other groups
the other groups being of course black
lives matter and antifa
have been painting all over everything
with little in the way of repercussions
let's just run through here uh some of
the um artwork
that the blm folks have have defaced the
city with
so you can see all that there the rich
aren't safe anymore uh
f donald trump acab
of course george floyd f the government
why do we have to keep telling you black
lives matter
well you don't actually just i'll answer
that question i don't know if it's
rhetorical or not but uh
you don't have to keep telling us that
as for why you do keep telling us that
i can't explain maybe you have maybe
there's some kind of maybe you have
tourette's or something
i don't know but you don't have to keep
telling us that because we all know
we all agree everyone agrees
fortunately okay it's a great thing it's
a
universal agreement united states uh on
on that point
now the fact that black pre-born lives
matter or that any pre-born life matters
that is something that does have to be
said that is a reminder that is actually
necessary
because pre-born people are legally
killed by the thousands the hundreds of
thousands in this country every year
so yes that is something that does need
to be said
in any case you see what blm has been
doing permanent markings
often on buildings compare that with
chalk on the sidewalk who gets arrested
here
we haven't even gotten to the most
egregious example yet speaking of
defacing public property
here's some defacement commissioned by
the mayor herself
black lives matter spray painted across
two entire city blocks
now you you compare the side by side
here on one hand
you've got pro-life message written in
chalk in tiny letters on one little slab
of the sidewalk
on the other you have black lives matter
spray painted in huge ugly yellow
letters across
two city blocks right down the middle of
street
one is illegal and will get you arrested
the other was not only sanctioned by the
by the mayor but commissioned by her and
just so you know
if you might say well if the mayor says
it's okay the mayor actually does not
have the authority to
spray paint her preferred political
messages all over the city
while arresting anyone who uses the same
medium
actually a less intrusive medium and
less permanent medium
to express their own preferred political
message this is called
viewpoint discrimination it is
ridiculously unconstitutional
you cannot do this i should say
it's not legal to do this they can do it
because they're doing it
um and this is the advantage that you
have
as a leftist your views are codified
protected um
you know uh
you you can you can get away with crimes
as as you are expressing your views as
long as they are the correct views
while if you're not a leftist you can be
arrested for expressing your own views
in a much less intrusive way
and much less destructive way we should
add leftist privilege is the real issue
in modern america
not white privilege and this is just the
latest exhibit of that
and that's why everyone involved except
for the pro-life advocates are
uh cancelled okay and we will wrap it up
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
top democrats strategize on stealing the
election representative john lewis's
funeral highlights political double
standards
and aoc attacks a saint check it out on
the michael knowles show